الصحفي الاكثر جدلا يعود مجددا كاشفا عن
قضايا ساخنه فبعد ان اتهم امريكا بتفجير
خط الغاز نورد ستريم يعود ويضع الرئيس
الاوكراني في دائره اتهام بالفساد ما هي
الا رساله من المخابرات الامريكيه وضعت
زينينسكي بين فكيهرش
رساله سريه بين مدير وكاله المخابرات
الامريكيه ويليامبرز والرئيس الاوكراني
تتضمن قائمه لعشرات المسؤولين الاوكرانيين
الفاسدين بينهم زيلينسكي التجاره مع العدو
عنوان مقاله هرش تشير بالارقام الى تعاون
زيلينسكي مع عدوته روسيا من خلال شراء
الوقود من المساعدات الامريكيه وهو ما
وصفه هرش بالاحتيال المالي
قال لي احد مسؤولي المخابرات الامريكيه
المطلعين كان زالنسكي يشتري الوقود بسعر
منخفض من الروس ومن يدفع ثمن الغاز والنفط
نحن الامريكيون بوتين وحكومته يكسبون
الملايين من ذلك حيث دفع البنتاجون ما
يقدر ب 400 مليون دولار للعمل الماضي
كشف احد مسئولي المخابرات لهرج ايضا
النازلينسكي متهم فيما يعرف بتجاره الحرب
والسلاح واكثر من ذلك انشاء شركات وهميه
بهدف ابرام عقود مع تجار اسلحه حول العالم
قيل لي ان العديد من الوزارات الحكوميه في
كييف كانت تتنافس حرفيا لانشاء شركات
واجهه لعقود تصدير الاسلحه والذخيره مع
تجار الاسلحه المستقلين في جميع انحاء
العالم يوجد العديد من هذه الشركات في
بولندا وتشيكو اسرائيل
كانت ضغط الامريكي وراء حمله مكافحه
الفساد في اوكرانيا قبل اربعه اشهر وفق
هرش حيث قدمت امريكا قائمه من 35 مسؤولا
اوكرانيا فاسدا وطلبت اقالتهم لكن
زيلينسكي اكتفى باقاله عشره فقط
مقالوا هرش لن يمر مرورا عاديا فهو ذاته
الذي كشف عن تورط المخابرات الامريكيه
بتفجير انبوب نورد ستريم تعرض هرش بعدها
لهجوم كبير من الاداره الامريكيه حيث اتهم
بانه عنصر في الدعايه الروسيه غذاء السالم
العربيه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات